Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to create beautiful virtual
clothes and marvel at how quickly we can simulate
them.
And the kicker is that these simulations are
able to create details that are so tiny, they
are smaller than a millimeter.
When I first saw this title of this paper,
I had two thoughts.
First I asked, submillimeter level?
Is this really necessary?
Well, here is a dress rendered at the level
of millimeters.
And here is what it would look like with this
new simulation technique.
Hm, so many crisp details suddenly appeared.
Okay, you got me, I am now converted.
So let’s proceed to the second issue - here
I also said I will believe this kind of quality
in a simulation when I see it.
So, how does this work?
Well, we can give it a piece of coarse input
geometry, and this new technique synthesizes
and simulates additional wrinkles on it.
For instance, here, we can add these vertical
shirring patterns to it.
And not only that, but we can still manage
collision detection, so it can interact with
other objects and suddenly, the whole piece
looks beautifully lifelike.
And as you see here, the direction of these
patterns can be chosen by us, and, it gets
better, because it can handle other kinds
of patterns too.
I am a light transport researcher by trade,
and I am very pleased by how beautifully these
specular highlights are playing with the light.
So good.
Now, let’s see it in practice.
On the left, you see the coarse geometry input,
and on the right, you see the magical new
clothes this new method can create from them.
And, yes, this is it!
Finally!
I always wondered why virtual characters with
simulated clothes always looked a little flat
for many years now.
These are the details that were missing.
Just look at the difference this makes!
Loving it.
But, how does this stack up agains previous
methods?
Well, here is a previous technique from last
year.
And here is the new one.
Okay.
How do we know which one is really better?
Well, we do it in terms of mathematics, and,
when looking at the relative errors from a
reference simulation, the new one is more
accurate.
Great.
But, hold on to your papers, because here
comes the best part!
Whoa!
It is not only more accurate, but it is blistering
fast.
Easily eight times faster than this previous
method.
So, where does this put us in terms of total
execution time?
At approximately one second per frame, often
even less.
What?
One second per image for a crisp, submillimeter
level cloth simulation that is also quite
accurate?
Wow.
The pace of progress in computer graphics
research is absolutely amazing.
And just imagine what we will be able to do
just two more papers down the line.
This might run in real time easily.
Now, drawbacks.
Well, not really a drawback, but there are
cases where the submillimeter simulation results
materialize in a bit more crisp creases…but
not much more.
I really had to go to hunt for differences
in this one.
If you have spotted stark differences between
the two here, please let me know in the comments.
And here comes one more amazing thing: this
paper was written by Huamin Wang and…that’s
it.
A single author paper that has been accepted
to the SIGGRAPH conference, which is perhaps
the most prestigious conference in computer
graphics.
That is a rare sight indeed.
You see, sometimes even a single researcher
can
make all the difference.
Huge congratulations!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!